it's great to have back on the program
after
i don't know how many years really it
feels like a long time ago
holyoke massachusetts mayor alex morse
who now also is candidate for congress
in massachusetts first congressional
district my old district i don't live
there
anymore but it was it was my district
for a while alex it's great to have you
on
yeah thanks so much for having me back
david i think it's been about nine years
i think it has been that long yeah at
the time we were both much younger last
time
yeah but we look the same we look
exactly the same that's the good news
yeah at least for now five more years
will be a little different
anyway if trump wins for sure um okay so
you're mayor of holyoke and you're
running this democratic primary campaign
the primaries on september 1st um
people should already have requested and
hopefully have in hand
ballots if they're voting absentee i
know people that have already
sent them back in so this this is all
sort of happening right now
talk a little bit about your approach
here
as someone who is up against the
longtime
incumbent in richard neal someone that
is seen by some as part of the
establishment someone that is seen by
others as someone who
maybe is doing a good enough job where
where they would not want to see him
replace
what's your approach here yeah so we
launched this campaign
about 13 months ago we knew it would
take a great deal of work to build the
kind of movement across western mass
this is a district of 87
cities and towns from the hilltown so
the berkshires rural parts of this
district down to
urban communities like springfield and
holyoke and so you know we have a member
of congress now that just
is unable to grasp the urgency of the
moment on every issue
he's absent he's unaccountable and he's
been there for over 30 years and it's a
different time than it was
in the late 1980s and it requires
a different a different sort of lens of
which we view policy
and just different solutions to the
challenges that we now have
and so our goal has always been to build
a grassroots campaign we always knew we
would get outspent
and outraised and our goal was to make
sure that we have the people power
the grassroots campaign and the
resources that we need to defeat
this congressman on september 1st and
you know 12 months later
and 13 days out from the election we are
well on our way
to doing that and it's a testament to
the people that have just felt forgotten
about and left behind
by the federal government in in recent
years so we'll talk
you've had some big boosts in
fundraising over the last seven days and
we'll talk about the genesis of all of
that in a bit
but as you point out this is a district
that includes springfield massachusetts
a city that has a very very different
circumstances
and problems than places like i think
huntington is also part of the district
or you know
another very rural small town with
one stoplight if anything so i mean the
what what huntington needs and what
springfield needs are two very very
different things
how do you assess working on both
yeah and so just yesterday we announced
the support of over 30
rural elected officials and community
leaders
who feel very much forgotten about and
left behind that
the perception now is not only do we
have a member of congress that hasn't
had a town hall in the district in over
three years
but people want a member of congress
that shows up in particular
in the hilltowns and in the rural parts
of the district and whether you live in
holyoke or springfield or huntington
or chester or north adams people are
feeling again
not represented by this current occupant
of of this seat
and you would never know we have one of
the most powerful members of congress
representing us when you look at
outcomes the fact that dozens of cities
and towns still are without
basic access to broadband internet that
we have public schools closing in the
hilltowns that can't afford the cost of
municipal health insurance
we have hospitals closing one in north
adams hundreds of inpatient psychiatric
beds closing here
in in holyoke and hampden county and
springfield still the asthma capital
of our entire country and i've made a
commitment to having a rural desk
making sure that we have a staff and a
presence in the hilltowns and in the
rural parts of this district
to make sure that everybody that lives
here in western and central mass knows
that they have an
ally in washington so most of my
audience obviously doesn't live in the
massachusetts first congressional
district but they
they live in the united states and so if
you were to become
a member of congress you would be one of
435 votes on a whole bunch of things
that would affect people who are in
florida or los angeles or or wherever
so i'd like to talk a little bit about
your your approach to some of the big
issues
right now that can sometimes be dividing
lines when we think about who should be
representing us so like for example big
picture
on taxation we had a tax reform bill in
2017
from the current administration and
republicans there's
a view that taxes should be much higher
on some
people or lower on others or whatever
the case may be
to pick an issue that is relatable to
everybody
what's your perspective on what congress
should be doing on taxes
yeah and i would i'll get to taxes in a
moment but this is a race
and i want listeners to know that has
national implications because
i'm challenging the chairman of the
house ways and means committee
and i'm not contesting the fact that
congressman neil has power
he has power as the chair of the ways
and means committee but he's not using
his power number one to hold this
president accountable
he dragged his feet for months to even
request the president's tax returns
refused to seize the new york state
returns that lawmakers there
worked for years to make available he
was one of the last congressional
democrats to embrace and support an
impeachment inquiry
into this president and along with
elliott engel is the only other
democratic chair in leadership
that hasn't had a single oversight
hearing on any component of the trump
administration
since the democrats took back the house
and so instead of using his power for
oversight
he's using his power to again be
complicit
in many of the priorities of the trump
administration he is an ardent opponent
of medicare for all
even as millions of americans are losing
their job and their employer-based
health insurance
he's the only member of congress here in
massachusetts that refuses to sign on
to the green new deal he even in the
middle of this pandemic has come out
against
a monthly recurring payment of two
thousand dollars to the most vulnerable
americans
that are being left behind he has
opposed pramila jayapal's paycheck
guarantee act
and right now he is literally the number
one recipient of corporate money
and the entire house of representatives
more than any democrat and even more
than every republican
and in regards to taxation in particular
yes this is a
congress a democrat that is openly
opposed to a wealth tax
he has supported the carried interest
loophole
i mean the ways and means committee in
particular is the committee that should
be doing oversight hearings
on the 2017 tax package he has done
nothing to address it
he has done nothing to raise the
corporate tax rate instead he's using
his power
to mitigate the possibility politically
of achieving a wealth tax and if we
defeat congressman neil on september 1st
it's all but
assured that there will be a member of
the progressive caucus that becomes
chair of the ways and means committee
that supports medicare for all that
supports a green new deal that supports
a wealth tax and a higher corporate tax
rate that we can actually invest in
domestic priorities
that would make a difference in people's
lives here in western mass okay but to
get back to my question
a little bit um on as let's go
even more detailed then so you mentioned
a wealth tax
you mentioned a recurring payment during
during the pandemic our current top
marginal tax rate right now is in the
mid 30s
where do you think the top marginal tax
rate should be do you want to see
a higher bracket at 45 50
70 as some other potential future
colleagues of yours have suggested where
would you put that
yeah i'm much more in line with
elizabeth warren's concept of a wealth
tax that the wealthiest one percent
um you know be it a penny or two on
every dollar over a certain amount of
money
and it is criminal in this country that
working families and middle-class
families are paying essentially more
in taxes to the federal government than
you know
folks at facebook and google and amazon
i mean
as a percentage of income you mean as a
percentage of income absolutely
and i think we also need to take a
closer look at modern
monetary theory i mean these archaic
views of the deficit and government
spending
i mean we have the resources we need to
fight climate change to provide
health care as a fundamental human right
to provide free public college but when
you have democrats
like congressman neil peddling
right-wing talking points about the
deficit and our inability to make these
investments
at the very time 60 percent of our
federal budget goes to the pentagon
i mean we need members of congress not
just not just any democrat but democrats
that actually understand this
um to go to washington and just change
the conversation in regards to these
issues
on pentagon funding how specifically
would you propose
reducing it i mean would you close bases
in places like germany for example
yeah i think i think first and foremost
we need to evaluate the necessity of
having
dozens of military bases around the
world and i think we need to have a
foreign policy that isn't
isn't eager to to sort of get itself
involved in unnecessary coups of
democratically elected leaders
around the world um and when we think
again sixty percent of our federal
budget goes to war and defense
i think is completely unacceptable and i
think there was some good effort among
the democrats to reduce it by 10
but i think i mean that's the floor and
i think we need to continue going
further than that
so this race the massachusetts first
congressional district has been not only
does it have national implications as
you point out
but it's also become very interesting to
all sorts of different
folks around the country over the last
10 days because of a controversy that
started when
the massachusetts college democrats put
out a letter
sort of generally alleging but without
naming any individuals or putting names
to it
alleged inappropriate actions by you
when it comes to personal relationships
when you were teaching a course at the
university of massachusetts
and in your role there working with with
college democrats at umass
and this has exploded to the point where
you know glenn greenwald
has been tweeting about it um ryan
you know all sorts of people i follow
unfit you know i've known you for a
decade and people that
had i had never mentioned you before
tweeting about it this has exploded now
um you've been able to raise a lot of
money as a result
and i want to talk about whether you
think maybe it is backfired to some
degree but
first of all the sort of core of it is
do you accept that you have acted
inappropriately
at any point in any way or do you reject
the allegations on principle
i reject the allegations on principle i
mean evidence has now
come to light that essentially proves
that this was a coordinated political
attack
on behalf of supporters of the
congressman that were in fact
trying to curry favor with one of the
most powerful incumbents in washington
i mean this was a story that was shopped
around to mainstream media
for months and every journalist rejected
it because it was vague
it was non-specific no one would go on
record i mean this was essentially a
blog post
that was printed in a student newspaper
that was unamplified
to the local media by by media here
across massachusetts and by national
media outlets
and now thanks to the investigative
reporting of the intercept
and the journalists there we have now i
mean pretty much by the day
have learned more and more behind the
political motivations of this
that goes to the height of the
massachusetts democratic party
itself and i have been very clear and
unapologetic about my identity as a
young
single gay person and and not having to
apologize for having relationships
consensual relationships with other
adult men in my life
and do you you say that there are
individuals
associated with and looking to curry
favor with your opponent but at this
point do you allege that your opponent
either knew that this was being done or
was involved in any way
i mean i think it is certainly
suspicious and i will let the people of
the district come to their own
conclusions but i think people are
certainly seeing this for what it is
that three weeks before the most
competitive election that this member of
congress has ever seen
this suddenly happens i mean it is no
accident it is no coincidence
and so people are seeing through it and
then the language
that has been used in response i mean
age-old homophobic tropes
yes that have been youth thrive gay men
who are all too familiar with the
over-policing of our personal lives and
our sex lives
i mean this the response to this hasn't
just been an attack on me as a candidate
and as a person
and it has had a great impact but it's
been an attack on all of us in our
entire community and has certainly
invigorated our supporters invigorated
the people here in the district and has
invigorated and inspired people to get
off the sidelines into this race that
that weren't involved before it
certainly seems like
whoever orchestrated it it may have
backfired and i want to talk about that
a little bit in terms of the fundraising
on the facts before we move on from
from that alex the one if i were to say
there's one detail that remains
unclear to me and i think it's unclear
maybe
because it's not actually part of the
story is
were were their relationships with
people
you were teaching seems to be the detail
that has been alluded to but not said
clearly and maybe just getting
that on the record would be useful yeah
i have been very clear
about about not having relationships
with people in my
in my class i mean i've been very clear
about that i have never violated any
policies of the university
of massachusetts and i mean i entered
public life at 21 i started teaching a
class
occasionally at umass at age 25. i mean
you know i'm in western massachusetts
and i mean gay men in particular
are all too familiar with resorting to
the internet and dating apps
to meet other men and sometimes it's the
only safe space that we have
and so again i think i need to be very
clear
about this and i think this is also a
case
that will allow other young people other
single people other queer people
to feel like they too can run for office
without a fear that their personal life
and their sex life
will be the topic of conversation when
they want to focus on policy
and why they're getting into the race in
the first place has this backfired
in the sense that there's more
discussion now about
your race 13 days before the primary
than at any point during the 13 months
that you've been running this race
yeah i mean once i mean last week after
the intercept reported their first story
documenting the political motivation
behind this coordinated attack i mean we
raised in one day alone
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
wow i mean that is more than
that is more than we raised in a three
month period last year i mean our
previous high day was 27
000 and in one day last week we raised
130 000
and since since this initial story broke
by the daily collegian at umass
two fridays ago we've raised nearly
three hundred thousand dollars
from thousands and thousands of
grassroots donors and so
this has been this has certainly
led to more attention on the race but
what's most important is is the voters
and the people here in the district
and i mean there are now i mean just
yesterday we announced the support of 30
elected officials and leaders in the
rural parts of this district
this morning we announced the support of
eight out of 11 city councilors in
pittsfield the third largest city in the
district
councilors who who told me before that
they were going to sit on the sidelines
but have been inspired over the last
couple of weeks that want to turn the
page on these
old-school political tactics around the
politics of destruction rather than
actually focusing on policy and and so
people here in the district are
are making their own conclusions and
connections and this is exactly what
again
people don't like about our political
process so when you raise
when you get this influx of money and
there's 13 days left obviously
it's great to get money from all over
the country but you really need it in
the first district because that's where
you're running
what is actually done with the money
that's raised to get the vote out in
your favor
when we have 13 days to go like how is
the money actually used
well well listen i mean we're going up
against wall street's favorite democrat
i mean the number one recipient of
corporate pac money with millions of
dollars from big pharma
fossil fuel companies wall street firms
uh
credit card companies and so 100
of our contributions are from people and
so we compete and we invest those
resources on making sure we're up on tv
and we're up on radio and we have mail
pieces going to the mailboxes of
thousands of people here
in the district making sure folks on
facebook and instagram are seeing ads
and videos about the importance of this
race
and not only does congressman neil have
millions of dollars from corporations
but now he has dark money groups and
political action committees on his
behalf
investing in the race and so we know
we're getting outspent and outraised
and so every dollar that we raise right
now helps us close the gap
to make sure that we can communicate
with as many voters as possible before
the september first election
uh if if you were to um ultimately
become one of the 435
member members of congress on the virus
which at this point
is affecting people's lives it's
affecting culture it's affecting the
economy i mean it's it's affecting
everything at this point in time
are you leaning in the direction of of
pushing for a coordinated
shutdown if there is no vaccine or
effective treatment to really try to
properly do what maybe should have been
done by april 15th or where are you on
dealing with that
yeah i think i think we do need to have
a conversation unfortunately in this
country
it seems that capitalism and maximizing
profits
are our number one goal um at the
expense of working people and working
families and so
that's a tough issue to to change but i
think we need more members of congress
that are willing to talk about what we
should be actually valuing as a country
the fact that
in this district and in this country
young parents in particular
you know mothers are having to choose
between keeping a job
or raising a child or homeschooling and
if they can't go to work
at risk of losing their home of not
putting food on the table affording
their prescriptions
and we have a member of congress that
thinks a one-time payment of 1200
to people is enough at the same time
that he's helping create a 500 billion
dollar
fund for corporations i mean this
pandemic has only
amplified why i got in this race in the
first place that we have a federal
government that has no problem finding
resources to the wealthy
and corporate and special interests but
when it comes to working people of this
country
we can't seem to actually find the
resources to help the most vulnerable
people
in western massachusetts and so we have
a congressman again in the middle of a
pandemic
that just doesn't understand the urgency
here yeah the underlying fragility of
the economy which was always there i
mean nothing changed about that but it's
been exposed in fact how fragile a lot
of these systems that sometimes feel
very
robust actually are our friend rokhana
has actually been very strong on this
issue and has been really good at
keeping keeping the focus on that we've
been speaking with holyoke massachusetts
mayor alex morse who is also running in
the massachusetts first congressional
district democratic primary
uh people are voting now the the primary
is on september 1st
alex good luck it's so great to talk to
you again
and uh we we will be following this one
closely
great thank you so much david i really
appreciate it encourage folks to go to
alexmoresforconverse.com to join us in
the final stretch